gold bars do not default on their
obligations
they just don't
i'm simon mikhailovich i'm the managing
partner of the boolean reserve
which is a vehicle for managing private
bullion reserves of institutional and
high net worth investors outside the
financial system
people think that it's something strange
i manage private gold reserves but we
are at an inflection point
that only comes every three or four
generations with great changes in the
economy in the world and potentially on
the eve of a new world order and so this
type of environment is precisely the
environment of highly elevated systemic
risks
where
reserves which are independent stores of
value
become especially relevant for
portfolios and for investors and so
having perceived the potential need for
this a number of years ago in the wake
of the 2008 crisis this is something i
decided
one day would be a relevant
strategy so i started early
every ounce of gold that exists above
ground is owned by somebody
today's price it's about 10 trillion
dollars worth something like that it's
not that much actually in the scope of
financial markets fifty percent of it is
in jewelry roughly
about twenty percent is held by central
banks
about ten percent is used as an industry
and another twenty percent is owned by
investors even if tomorrow somebody
found massive deposits to actually
develop these deposits to the point
where bullion is refined and available
in the market it would take 10 years so
here's an asset with relatively
predictable supply we know exactly how
much of it exists it has a unique
molecular structure that cannot be
replicated and plus it has a very strong
proven record of offering portfolio
diversification particularly during
periods
of systemic disruptions bank failures
payment system failures uh catastrophic
cyber failures and things like that so
it's it's an asset that is inherently
independent from the financial system
from the cyber networks from the
counterparties
in the past 30 or 40 years most of the
wealth has migrated
to financial instruments
that
rely on leverage
rely on counterparties the world has
become more interconnected than it ever
has been and of course everybody thinks
that they're not exposed because they
are reinsured with each other so it's
like a daisy chain of obligations where
no single party thinks they have a lot
of exposure because they have laid that
exposure to other parties that is true
only so long as everybody can meet their
obligations what we saw in 2008 is that
a failure by one party
lehman in that case to meet their
obligation and when the time came for
them to actually pay on the promises
that they have made they couldn't do it
and that literally collapsed the entire
financial system so what we saw with
lehman brothers was a just a glimmer of
the kind of problem that could happen i
mean think of walking into an airplane
that has two engines
and all of a sudden realizing that if
the right one shuts down the left one
will automatically shut down as well now
what good is having two engines
if they come on and off at the same time
so what i see right now is i see
governments at the highest level of debt
ever
the interest of on which is at the
historic lows at the moment and the
government cannot afford for that
interest to go up i think we're in a
very difficult position and everybody
knows it's nothing i'm saying is some
sort of news
it's just everybody thinks yeah yeah
yeah but this has been going on for so
long it'll just keep on going forever
but there's always an end to this road
so if the debts have to be restructured
it means that there are assets that
somebody thinks is their savings pension
that are not worth what they think
they're worth
because they are backed by the debt that
cannot be repaid in real terms and
that's why central banks hold gold
reserves and that's why they're now
increasing their gold reserves because
they see what's coming
[Music]